ses looks à l'heure actuelle au canada
les municipalités ne sont informés qu
après le passage de wagons contenant des
matières dangereuses
[Musique]
selon la réglementation fédérale qui a
été adoptée après la tragédie de
lac-mégantic
les transporteurs ont l'obligation
d'informer les municipalités qui le
désirent
mais les renseignements sur les convois
ne doivent être envoyées qu'à la fin de
chaque trimestre
les responsables municipaux obtiennent
l'information sur les wagons comptant
les matières dangereuses plusieurs
semaines après leur passage
la fédération des municipalités
québécoises voudrait plutôt que les
compagnies ferroviaires informe les
villes avant et non après l'information
disponible avant le passage du train
les services d'urgence peuvent mieux
planifier d'éventuels d'intervention
[Applaudissements]
l'industrie ferroviaire nord américaines
ont néanmoins développer des outils pour
aider les municipalités
par exemple l'application ask où elle
permet aux premiers répondants de
connaître le contenu des wagons en
consultant leur téléphone cellulaire
il suffit d'enregistrer le numéro
d'identification des wagons pour savoir
quelles substances ya l'intérieur et
quels sont les risques qui y sont
associés
en terminant saviez vous que le
transport de pétrole brut et de mazout
par train a chuté de 75% dans l'est du
canada au cours des dernières années on
est passé d'environ 5000 miss un wagon
par mois en mars 2013 à environ mais 500
wagons en décembre 2017
cette baisse elle est essentiellement
causée par la chute du prix du baril de
pétrole sur les marchés mondiaux
il faut savoir que le transport par
train ça coûte cher et plus les prix
mondiaux sont bas - ça devient
intéressant de faire venir par train du
brut de l'ouest canadien mais si le prix
du baril pétrole continuent d'augmenter
comme c'est le cas actuellement
il ne serait pas étonnant de voir de
plus en plus de wagons sur les chemins
de fer de l'est du pays
[Musique]